the house select committee investigating
the assault on the capitol predicts
steve bannon's indictment will push
other witnesses to cooperate former
president trump's white house chief
strategist turned himself in yesterday
to face contempt of congress charges
he'll be back in court on thursday now
bannon faces possible jail time if he is
convicted senior investigative
correspondent that's katherine herrich
reports on bannon's case and the warning
that he offered as he turned himself in
we're here today i don't want anybody
take their eye off the ball everybody
get back
everybody from live streaming his
arrival as he surrendered to law
enforcement thanks guys appreciate it
this is going to be the misdemeanor from
hell to a news conference on the
courthouse steps former president
trump's adviser steve bannon maximized
the media exposure vowing his legal team
is on the offensive i'm never going to
back down and they they took on the
wrong guy this time inside the court
bannon's tone was more reserved as he
faced criminal contempt charges for
failing to comply with a congressional
subpoena from the committee
investigating the january 6 attack on
the u.s capitol
while he was not working in the white
house as the violence unfolded bannon's
lawyer said his communications with the
former president are still protected by
executive privilege and he claimed the
justice department criminal charges went
too far there is nothing about this case
that reflects the pursuit of the equal
justice under the law the select
committee hasn't indicated if it will
soon hold mark meadows the former white
house chief of staff in contempt after
he failed to show up for a deposition
last week but legal experts say bannon's
case sends a signal the reason the
committee brought the charge against
bannon was only partly to have a
reprisal against bannon and really more
to direct it to the marked meadows of
the world see what we can do if you
don't comply with the subpoena
right here
conditions for abandons pre-trial
release including surrendering his
passport plus prosecutors told this
court each count carries a fine of up to
a hundred thousand dollars that's more
than previously reported and up to a
year in jail tony
catherine thank you very much